So Hulu came out with its fourth installment of into the dark and it went a little something like this
After Pooka's success. I was really looking forward to this one. But damn I just can't do it guys
I can't give you some half-assed ending explain video where I talk about mirrors for 10 minutes
Seriously, this movie has more mirrors in it than Paris Hilton's house
So I've decided to make a new series called think storey takedowns
I wish I could tell you what this movies about but you don't even find out until 42 minutes into it
That's nothing much to tell. Yes for 42 minutes. Nothing happens
There's no action just four girls in a room talking about whether their friend bang Leonardo DiCaprio or not
They at least have the decency to change
locations to asana where they talk even more about crap that doesn't matter at all to the plot in all honesty this movie could probably
Be condensed to 10 to 15 minutes, but it was as if the producer said "Hey
We need to stretch this out and oh, can we have it set all in one location?"
it was so glaringly obvious that this movie was
Constrained by its budget and when that seeps into the story you start to get problems
But it's not just the pacing that has problems. The characters are a complete mess
So at that 42 minute mark
We finally learned what this movie is about
Four girls decide to reunite on New Year's only for three of them to tie up the other
And make her confess to killing a fifth girl. She mercilessly bullied into committing suicide years ago
And yes, it's that convoluted and yes, there are many problems. First of all, these girls have no exit plan
They commit not only kidnapping but assault to one of the most up-and-coming social media stars
How do they expect to get out of this and what if she refuses? Like she obviously will. Are they gonna kill her?
Of course not. So Alexis, our main character's big plan is to dress her up like old Greg. "Come on Craig."
Yeah, that'll do it Alexis, you got her now.
And this is where things go completely off the rails
Kayla the only somewhat reasonable character in this entire film
Rushes off to the bathroom not being able to take what's going on and Alexis follows leaving Chloe and Danielle all alone
Now Chloe is one of these stupidest characters. I have ever seen in any movie ever!
she decides to free Danielle after danielle promises her a segment on her new TV show like you actually
Believe her you just tied her up and were complicit in a crime you dumb-dumb. Her character arc is completely bonkers
She goes from Alexis's side to Danielle's
Then from just wanting to scare the girls they end up locking in the sauna for a bit
to flat out wanting to murder them, then feel sorry when she actually does kill Kayla then to feeling okay about it
She is all over the map and my favorite is how Danielle convinces Chloe to murder the others just by saying,
"You wouldn't want them to spread rumors about us, would you?"
"yes the old they might spread rumors so you should murder them" technique, but even more troublesome is our
Protagonist Alexis she is so extremely unlikable and unsympathetic, it's hard to root for her
Maybe we're supposed to feel bad because of her scar that she's a struggling babysitter
But you could probably take that out of the movie and it wouldn't change anything . And speaking of change,
her character doesn't go through any. She basically has this plan,
goes through with it, and doesn't learn anything along the way. And if we're gonna talk about the ending where she takes over as
Danelle's Protege, don't even get me started
How did she get away with all this? There were like three dead people in her house and her telling me people aren't like
"Hmm, Maybe she had something to do with this."
and even though Alexis has been talking in this video for over a minute, when we pull back it shows the video has only been
playing for 10 seconds
I guess that's the type of service you get on "totally tubular", but let's get back to some more stupid shit
Like Kayla's car breaking down right outside Alexis's house. RIGHT OUTSIDE!
What? It's like the writer was like, "okay, we need to have it so that they can't use the car,
But we need to get them there. What can we do? Oh, make it break down right when they get there."
Convenient, or how about the glass in every window of this home has been specially tempered
Someone falls out a window in your home and the logical thing to do is temper all the glass. Where the parents like
"Hey, we don't want another suicide kids running out our windows
Let's just be safe and install bulletproof glass in case anyone else wants to kill themselves again."
What? And speaking of death, the kills in this movie are pretty lame. Nothing new or exciting, it's all stuff
we've seen in other horror movies like knocking your head, or getting stabbed, and I think the editor kind of knew this because in order
To make the death of Chloe seem more shocking because she just kind of tumbles down the stairs and dies, They did this
I laughed out loud with the quick cuts of that music but the deaths are equally
Predictable because the director uses this technique called "Chekhov's gun"
Way too, literally
So for those of you don't know Chekhov's gun
Basically means if you show something like a gun
You better see it fired later on and damn
Do they use it here where the camera just lingers on a set of golf clubs for an awkward amount of time. Hmm
I wonder if those will come into play later on or how about these knives?
hmm also,
Why does Alexis throw Danielle's phone? Nearly smashing it. Don't they need that phone for their plan to expose Danielle on her own Instagram?
I mean they could use someone else's phone to log in but
What if she doesn't know her password?And last but not least for a horror movie,
There's almost no tension here
Because in order to have tension, we the audience need to have some piece of information that the characters do not. For example
And Kari how we know this bucket of blood might fall, but Kari doesn't that's tension
But because every characters motivations are hidden or extremely unclear for most of the film
There's almost none of this into the last 20 minutes of the movie. So, what did you think?
Did you like this heaping pile of garbage? Should I do more takedown videos?
leave a comment below and make sure to smash that like button as if it were made of tempered glass and until next time remember
Daddy loves you very much.